- But you're returning
to Dancing With The Stars
this fall is a judge.
So, which is harder,
is it harder being a pro
dancer there or a judge?
- Oh, being a pro dancer, for sure.
- It's hard.
- Being a judge is kush.
I'm not gonna lie.
- Yeah.
- I'm like and now dance
please, thank you, wonderful.
- Dance monkey.
- You've danced hours and
hours on end and good, not.
- Yeah.
- You know,
so I appreciate that though
'cause I did 17 seasons doing that
- Yeah.
- and, but
I'm excited about this season
'cause Len's gonna be back,
you know and so it was gonna
be four of us be on that judge.
- Yeah.
- I'm trying to think where I'm gonna sit,
I might just sit on his
lap and then, you know.
- Please do.
- What'd you think, Len?
What'd you think about that darling?
- What?
Would you ever go back and dance?
You know, I might.
I never say never.
I love the show so much, it's so much fun
and it would have to be
for like the right partner
or the right thing.
I don't know, I don't know.
- Wait, well who's the right partner?
Like it would be fun to.
- You know,
I've always said, I've
always said like Celine Dion,
because
- Oh my God.
- she, I met her once, a couple of times,
but the first time I met her
was on my first season of
Dancing With The Stars,
- Yeah.
- she performed and I was
walking up the stairs,
I was holding some shoes
and she goes, Derek Hough
and I'm like, Celine Dion knows my name.
And then I was like, I
didn't know what to say.
So I just said, I'm holding shoes.
(laughing)
- And she said,
she's like Derek Hough is
holding shoes, oh yeah.
And then just get a turn
- She just stared singing?
- and walked away and I was like,
the hell just happened, what?
- You just got serenaded by Celine Dion.
- I did and then later,
you know, further down the line I met her
and then she was telling
me, she goes, I love dance,
I dance after my shows.
She like, she'll do her show
and then she goes to dance class
and then does dance for a couple of hours.
I'm like, what?
- Oh.
- So she'd be great,
she'd be great.
- I need to hang out
with people like that,
okay, I'm like, what?
I'm like, sounds exhausting
- Yeah.
- after a day of work.
- I was pretty surprised
myself, I was surprised.
- Yeah, no, she's awesome though,
I didn't realize she danced so much,
but I saw her Vegas show
and I was like, she is, is she tired?
- Yeah.
- Like, 'cause of her
she also has like two sets
of lungs when she sings.